[Musique]
allez le deuxième sujet dont vous voulez
parler ce soir c'est la sécurité
routière alors là c'est un petit peu
plus sérieux parce que vous avez suivi
cette polémique autour du métrage
dénouera alors qu'arrive je vais vous
replacer un décor d'aller décrocher vous
avez bien avant les vacances
aussi j'ai tout décrocher et raccrocher
les encadreurs du jour donnant la
sécurité routière a fait appel à
plusieurs personnalités pour
sensibiliser contre l'alcool au volant
est l'un des clips mettant en scène donc
et nora qui raconter une anecdote avec
un ami et il ya eu quelques réactions
dont une de muriel cousin la compagne de
stéphane guillon qui a taclé nos rages
vous dire ce qu'elle a mis ensuite sur
twitter
regardez ce spot et dites-nous s'il ya
quelque chose qui vous choque qu'on s'y
voilà ici vous êtes d'accord avec enora
de défendre ce spot regarde un soir
après un dîner déjà bien arrosée on
décide de partir en boîte avec toute une
bande de potes il ya un pote à nous
qu'ils nous saoulent pendant une heure
pour qu'on monte dans sa voiture et nous
on insiste et ont dit non et on est
content de dire non parce qu'aujourd'hui
on ait envie et lui malheureusement sur
le trajet miles & more alors n'hésitez
pas vous n'êtes pas ridicule dit non
voilà alors y arrive c'est bien alors je
vais vous dire non mais voilà et blême
muriel cousin la compagne de stéphane
guillon a taclé north après la diffusion
de cette vidéo
et il ya quelques personnes voilà qui
ont réagi je pense que c'est les mêmes
personnes qui kings queens nation un qui
est la vie mais elle est sérieuse ce
qu'il fallait faire c'est dire non aussi
à son pote et le protéger à sécuritaire
ce n'est pas être conne est derrière
vous a traité de petit sas au sein de
[ __ ] de voile a été levé la tête voilà
et donc
elle a été assez violente sur twitter on
dirait envers vous flamatt voilà donc
alors pensez vous que la polémique
autour des nora est justifié voilà après
ou bien est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que parce qu'en fait la polémique qu'on
lui dit voilà il aurait fallu que tu
dises à ton pote nom ne prend pas la
voiture mais évidemment c'est ce qui
implicitement dans son message
elle explique clairement que en violant
non halal elle sauvait sa vie et que et
l falaise y renoncer le seul message
alors franchement des fois une ode et
des conneries mais mais mais là c'est
tellement ils sont alors on ne peut plus
rien faire on fait un truc bien on ne le
sait pas bien j'ai un truc énorme sur la
maison je croise le livre a raconté
cette anecdote aux téléspectateurs c'est
que c'est quand même et on a offert une
maison une des spectatrices et voilà une
jeune femme qui en avait besoin et
vraiment on était hyper content de le
faire lors de la grande régalade juste
avant noël et j'ai vu le lendemain plein
de sites qui mettait attention elle
n'aura pas la maison elle ne l'aura
conjointe va forcément faut la
construire des douits mais les gars mais
c'est comme tout et donc les mecs
polémique
les maires les mecs tu écris ça c'est le
seul mec quand ils achètent une maison
il lui arrive direct il a déclaré
faussement les maintenances et c'est
bernard morin dans les mondes et fo mais
non mais voilà donc on critique pas tout
le monde comme on l'a dit car il ya des
gens qui font très bien leur travail et
plein de journalistes qui font très bien
leur travail d'ailleurs il ya que des
journalistes pratiquement autour de la
table mais c'est vrai qu'il y en a
certains il faut qu'ils vérifient
parfois les infos puisque c'est c'est
compliqué thierry c'est surtout que moi
je connaissais pas l'histoire donc je ne
sais pas si elle n'aura n'a pas essayé
de prendre les clés du mec c'est n'a pas
essayé de l'empêcher de la voiture une
vraie histoire ne connaît pas l'histoire
donc pris dans meetic la vérité moi je
suis passé un spot ne sais pas non ce ne
sont pas des siennes en a parlé ici en
plus sur le journal parlé en cible
j'écoute pas tout ce qu'elle dit est
enfin nommé déjà nommé désir il c'est un
spot pour la sécurité routière
non mais je crois justement parce que je
pensais qu'il avait été écrit par la
securitate c'est connaître mais non non
non non alors là c'est un spot
effectivement il faut raconter des
anecdotes corps nous ont appelés mais
c'est un spot qui a été validé par la
sécurité routière puisque oui mais
c'était important
oui et voilà pourrait normalement mais
c'est vrai la sécurité routière demande
chaque année un des animateurs et des
cours alain coeur de témoigner parce que
enora voilà elle est ici donc elle
touche les jeunes sortis le public de
tpm
on fait ça gratuitement évidemment elle
dit ce qu'elle a sur le coeur et la boum
derrière c'était pas ça se fait défoncer
un moment donné tout fait buzz tout fait
polémique
les gens me mais ça devient d'un gars
eux le monde devient dingue hein c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut plus rien dire peut
plus rien faire un peu de bienveillance
un peu de bonheur un peu de gentillesse
en 2010 est de toute façon on sera
toujours soupçonné de d'être mal
intentionnés d'avoir un tour derrière de
ses chiens non mais c'est chose est sûre
section au sollicite enora je pense
qu'elle réfléchir à deux fois avant 2 2
dans une campagne on dire ah bah voilà
arrêt dans sa tour d'ivoire y en a rien
à [ __ ] des amériques vous qui n'êtes
pas dans la bande de tpm pistes pour ça
que je dois à chaque fois tous les soirs
d'ailleurs à quelqu'un d'extérieur pour
qu'on dise pas qu'on est entre nous donc
forcément qu'on a toujours le même avis
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
politique franchement ben moi j'ai
appris la polémique avant de regarder le
spot donc j'en attendais à quelque chose
éventuellement voilà nos pattes d'oie il
n'aura quant à elle respecte et
finalement ceux ci mais oui pour le
problème est unique
j'ai trouvé sincère touchante donc non
et derrière jeu comme on a un peu suivi
l'actu autour de stéphane guillon mais
le cousin de sita a quand même mis un
gros de mon coeur c'est facile et d'un
règlement de comptes qui m'a redonné moi
qui ne voient là qui n'échappe qui
entreront vous enfin au parfum vous même
pas entre stéphane guillon tout seul je
ne sais pas pourquoi et j'ai
l'impression que sa compagnie si on
règle ses comptes
alors qu'elle juge peut-être le spot
maladroit pourquoi pas chaque fois
laroche rouges pour que chacun fait ce
qu'il veut moubarak dont les uns des
vivaces et par contre quel insu et oui
ça s'appelle de la diffamation et ça ça
se réglera autrement mais je trouve ça
très triste parce que là il s'agit de
d'aider des jeunes alors là nulle part
crever
les analyses
vraiment c'est pas une thèse sur les
accidents et comment empêcher les
gentillesses de seconde va forcément à
l'essentiel on attend quand même un tout
petit peu astucieux pour comprendre ce
qu'il ya entre les visions qui les
empêcherait de et moi j'étais dans un
coin où rien passé à part les chevreuils
ce week-end
je suis heureux ça au retour je me dis
mais c'est effarant la place que prend
maintenant chaque chose passait assez à
berru mais m'invite compagnie plus en
plus mal il comprit aussi si super match
extérieur vous dites aussi parfois que
gens sont même exigence bienvenue lé
pari que font mal leur boulot qu'ils
feraient mieux de dégager vous avez
sûrement vu une certaine haine de
certains professionnels assurés et on
peut vous pouvez pas vous plaindre aussi
si à chaque fois que maintenant vous
vous faites quelque chose parce que new
delhi pour moi si je peux me permettre
car il aussi mis ta raison car quand il
ya juste un truc c'est qu'ici dans cette
émission il ya chez nous un c'est pas d'
insulte non mais si on dira donc un
accord national a dit non elle a raison
car une honda on l'a déjà dit ce qui
dégage il a été déjà très violents 90
les chéris justice vous pouvez laissez
moi parler ici quoi qu'il arrive dans
l'émission y en a toujours un qui va
dire je n'aime pas télé iniateurs où il
y aura toujours quelqu'un d'autre pour
le défendre
ça c'est sûr il ya c'est très rare qu'un
animateur fasse l'unanimité pour ou
contre lui ou qu'une émission fasse
l'unanimité pour ou contre l donc il ya
toujours un contrepoids là c'est vrai
que c'est voilà sur cette affaire-là
s'est attaquée pour attaquer je trouve
que la voilà arrivés après moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous il ya on
a on a dit plein de choses sur des
journées pour des journaux télé ce jour
des journalistes sur des émissions sur
des chaînes mais c'est le principe de
l'émission c'est normal on est à un
retour de bâton et ça on le comprend
tout à fait et c'est normal qu'on soit
critiquée alors c'est vraiment et
continue à nous critiquer et je pense
que c'est quand on sera plus critique
est ce qu on n'existera plus donc c'est
c'est le plus important gilles verdez je
suis tout à fait d'accord quand ce bien
des choses violentes comme répondant
mais qu'on me réponde karine puisqu'on
n'est pas regardée en sur le plateau
voilà non mais là bas on peut répondre
dans d'autres médias les gens le font
les normales sans fin mais là non mais
là c'est pas la personne de noro la
chronique que c'est la cause qu'on en a
un mais c'était la personne la violence
du tweet de muriel cousin ça fait aussi
du mal à l'attaqué elle est arrivée au
mauvais endroit au bon moment
elle a voulu attaquer n'aura pour un
truc les studios premier truc à faire
jouer l'attaqué et ce n'était pas le bon
moment c'est à dire y'a mon y avons
patrick sébastien qui m'envoie un pied
sms que j'embrasse or patrick bonne
année à lui bizot a une aura son message
était
bien on embrasse patrick qui l'on
regarde voilà merci battu mois patrick
[Applaudissements]